you're listening to the hp podcast
oh my god we're here i'm late
you guys i'm telling you man whenever
i'm a little bit late we got everybody
in the chat
threatening to take my wiki feed score
that's right
you support that well i want you to be
on time
well i'm doing important things i'm
trying to i'm like on social media i'm
trying to promote the show and meanwhile
i got
everyone on my back trying to threaten
me to take my waking feet i mean
if i'm not number one then who am i i
just think it's good that people have a
power
to do something and if it's through a
wicked fit
um that's you sh i can't believe you're
siding with them
you know if i ever got into it in a
scandal do you think our fans would tank
my wikipedia
that would be like the whole thing
that'd be the first thing that they do
what could i do to make our fans turn on
me on wiki feet
late to a live show apparently not much
what you're saying apparently nothing at
all
so i don't know how many people watched
our last podcast
but we discovered actually can someone
drop the
the night paralysis in the chat because
i want to just make sure we're all on
the same page because we're going to be
doing this all
all episode long there's this clip of
james charles going
uh
[Music]
so we were having an internal debate oh
did i say our sponsors today we're
sponsored by keeps and mint mobile
lots to talk about today jake paul oh
brother brother brother
if you thought the fbi raid in your
house was bad wait just do that
you guys remember that oh man you
remember the fbi raiders house nothing
came with that wasn't with that
i don't know it was all very mysterious
yeah
you're tripping raise this house and
seize like an armory
i guess he legally owned his weapons
though fair enough
he's like yeah no no i
this bazookas has a registration
in america you never know
it's for killing deer you know like a
whole [ __ ] uh stampede of them in 10
seconds
okay so here's uh what i said
oh someone why did it say that someone
able someone added that to the closed
caption
i thought they disabled the closed
caption
where people could automatically submit
god you know people used to be able to
add their own closed caption yeah
it was a utopia so that's not a thing
anymore i think because
people were writing like horrible things
in there okay
well yeah as you could expect
people to do but like for the most part
it worked really well
you know and people were so kind they
just went out i know our friends were
being pretty funny with it i remember
yeah they put in little little goofs but
cough trademark
right tiana right after the cough anyway
here's the sleep paralysis james charles
you're gonna be hearing a lot of this
this is basically the best
new hot thing on the street you wake up
it's from two years ago well on this
show
on the street you wake up and this is
looming over you what do you do
you're stuck do you know what's have you
ever had sleep paralysis
i haven't but i heard about it from you
you're stuck in a room
when i have uh sleep paralysis it's
different for everyone i'm stuck
in a infinite white void and i'm
paralyzed
i can hear things but there's nothing
just empty whiteness
sounds awful like in the matrix yes
[Music]
in stranger things when she gets into
the black
thing with like water on the bottom kind
of feels like it's like
it's i think the best it's literally
like dan said in the matrix when you zip
in but so i'm just laying this infinite
white void
paralyzed and then and it's scary
oh so it's terrifying it's terrifying
and apparently some people have demons
in there i've had that only a few times
but oh my god that
it i i don't usually get demons jesus or
there's some you get the sensation that
there's some kind of
um threatening entity there with you
it's always been wally and he's just
like wake up i'll wake up i wish
an encouraging voice from wally wake up
i didn't anyway this is the most
terrifying sleep paralysis demon of all
[Music]
i love the face expressions it takes it
so seriously
only your eyes can move
because maybe that's how youtube
interpreted it
how you doing ayla we haven't seen you
all week here on the show um
this clip made my whole week way better
you heard me just doing yeah yeah yeah
yeah i love it i've been good
just working a lot on teddy's fresh
yeah this shirt's nice
nice um everyone's getting vaccinated at
the office so
we're starting to feel a little relieved
that maybe someday
things will be normal i don't know
but at least it's starting to feel like
not as scary
to to have to go to work in the office
because we really have to it's like
i feel like we pushed working at home as
far as we could it's
done we just we can't continue to work
at home
right we're we're we're all almost
vaccinated too now my dog bite is
killing me i don't know if that's bad
it's like i guess i think it's healing
because it's itching a lot mm-hmm
so maybe it's good but it's really
annoying
it's just in the worst place because
it's right on my joint
also i wash my hands all the time so
it's like
it's really annoying um
do you is your favorite part of this the
yeah yeah yeah or the won't want
the yeah yeah yeah me too
because it's like so deep yeah yeah yeah
some of you guys were saying was your
favorite
and that kind of it's definitely a
package you know can i get it can
everybody come on speak up okay no i'm
with you guys i'm filling with you guys
i mean the womps are fine
[Music]
i should have [ __ ] known zach
i mean the whomp is good i'm not going
to judge you what does the aunt think
uh yeah yeah you guys are good yeah love
go ahead what do you think
i think i like the bumps more what oh my
god
we're perfectly
[Laughter]
um i mean yeah it's four to three
should we take a straw poll on this the
the yeah we should
okay let's see here just to remind you
guys are you okay
let me defend let me make an argument
for yeah yeah yes
he's trying so hard and it's so deep
and it's like so much deeper than um
what is this photograph tag what the
what
oh see that's why they erase the entire
i don't know i guess maybe you guys were
noticing but the whole yeah it's
probably custody i haven't noticed it
until now
jesus christ there was a lot of stuff
flashing on screen
and then it's just the whomp bump is
just it's over so
i love the womps though is that a lyric
that's in the original
womp i don't think no it's like he's
just sounding out the
the it's the sound yeah the music is
freestyling
right yeah okay it's pretty funny to
bust out a wonk
what is that he thinks he's doing
something he really
like i can't put it into words what it
is
also like he why does he look like
it looks like um we were saying he looks
like the panzer labyrinth like he's so
the band's labyrinth yeah yeah i don't
remember that
we have a photo of it yeah because you
have the the cam grants one
yeah yeah can grants came out with the
oh my god oh my god
here this is the striker belly
[Laughter]
he's so pale and doing his face in
proportions
so how are the results looking let's see
we have an upset here
an upset yeah we have a whomp bombs
taking the lead
well i'm yeah yeah yeah you know me
that's what i'm saying
go to brazil wow
okay the womps
i mean look they're funny the whomp womp
womp definitely
you know what i mean that's not my
dictionary it's not my
vocabulary
interesting i think you never assume
that you know everything about the world
the thing i think the yes is a little
more subtle appreciation
oh you need a more refined uh you need a
little higher iq
i think the gas is a little bit more
refined of appreciation
the
it's like he's on a roller coaster when
he starts
yeah but you got to decide you like the
fall we like to build up
right well yeah what is this
like a fish gasping for air
like a proud mom
[Laughter]
that that image i grabbed the other day
and it just accidentally like i got a
frame that was like all blurry and scary
looking with his eyes like beady
why doesn't he send a picture like this
to his snapchat victims with little
hearts under them
[Music]
[Laughter]
i didn't think about that um
next up dan really wants me to watch
this one
you got i think you guys overestimate
the importance of
wall-e oh well i just want it as a cold
open
yeah and you were denied my request
because
well here i just wanted the show to open
with this with no contact
yeah but nobody's gonna walk oh god
it's wrong
like what is that he is talking he's
like somehow makes that
sound with his voice oh my god it's so
loud he's literally talking
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay you want uh caitlyn jenner on this
math singer i
saw this and i thought it wasn't real at
first i thought it was
you know caitlyn jenner was on the math
singer
and when i first saw this i was like
this is not edit this is
edited right like somebody edited pieces
together to make it look more awkward
than it is have you seen this
i have oh my god but
apparently this is real
[Applause]
but what's the premise of it what is the
premise of the singer
yeah it's like a contest show and the
format is there's a bunch of people in
like really elaborate costumes they're
all like animals or like
something like that and you know it's
like an elimination show
like any of those stuff whatever yeah
singing but do they
try to actually sing yeah yeah they do
and so nobody knows who they are
was but they're like kind of good which
will be
well some of them are but then some of
them are what we're about to see
so did she get eliminated the first
round so i'm i'm assuming so
uh if this is what it sounded like
because they don't they don't unmask
them until
they're either eliminated or they win or
whatever so uh
i'm assuming she got got the boot pretty
quick
bro
bro you think they didn't oh my god how
do you submit yourself to that i will
not do this please god help me if i
i guess you're pretty brave to even go
on the show
brave or death i mean yeah receiving
attention
logan paul was recently on the show oh
on the mass singer
yes yeah what yeah how did we miss that
i mean i didn't see the footage i just
saw like on twitter do you watch it ab
i i seen the clip but i don't watch the
show
if you can find that yeah let's watch
this first and then we'll watch logan
but okay
i'll grab that i'll just come out there
and be like yeah
where i stand if my career ever comes to
the point of being on dancing with stars
or the mass singer
i would rather die i'd rather die kill
me now
strike me down heavenly father where i
stand
if i ever go on like okay we got it
funny though people in the chat are
saying wendy williams was on the math
center
pull it away oh we just hit the [ __ ]
jackpot yeah well i was just gonna say
maybe i'm not flattering myself maybe
we're kind of missing out
on the greatest show actually oh yeah
maybe we should try
watching it but i think i'm flattering
myself like the math singer wants my
dumb ass
right they'll be like excuse me we're
weird no one is even gonna get no
there's a lot of people on there that
are like
they pull off the mask and you're like
bro they sent me an
email dude this is hilarious wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait
the mass singer sent you in yeah didn't
i show you which
wait it was exactly on the same day that
you guys sent us this clip and we were
all laughing at it
so i saw so one of the producers sent me
an email and i was like oh my god
they're gonna invite me on the math
singer
but i was like how did they know we were
just talking if you guys want to know
how b-list i am
b might even be generous c yeah okay so
so i don't know if there's i guess if
you're like b-list gets you on the math
singer
then whatever you guess what list i am
they go
hey they go the conf oh it's
confidential [ __ ] you you sent me
unsolicited email it's not confidential
i guess they don't want to know how like
cringe their marketing is
can you send someone an unsolicited
email to your work email that's
that's confidential no of course not
although i mean if you want to get on
the show maybe i don't play and i'm
begging you please
all right well then let's let's hear
what they had to say so it says mass
singer confidential i was like holy [ __ ]
whoa dear ethan my name is yada yada
yada from smart dog media we are the
creators of the mass singer
she says we think your podcasts are
awesome and we love your array of topics
you cover
thank you that's very nice of them she
says this is a last-minute ask but i was
wondering if you might be
interested in live
tweeting the east coast airing of the
mass singer tonight
hold on what their we would love to
engage with you
with your live tweets if you could make
commentary on twitter
as the show airs
so sometimes i see celebrities or people
in general not even a bad gig not a paid
gig
so why because the opportunity to be
for them to interact with my tweets it's
so like
the masked singer twitter account yes oh
my god you're gonna retweet me
that's so sick
i don't know what list that makes me
should i just let them retweet you
and then it's the one-point list
oh the [ __ ] does outreach thank you like
okay you like my twitter
put a mask on me [ __ ] right so you
would you would never do that
if they ask you not a chance never zero
not a chance in the world matt singer
has 300
000 followers on twitter sounding to me
like you're saying mass
singer masked right mask but i guess
it's like silence say masked
try saying that word rest mask
masked i mean really what do you want
everyone's always [ __ ] on me all the
time about it
do you know what i'm on the edge of the
observation i haven't eaten a day
on you i have not eaten a decent meal in
two weeks i am suffering
xxx taction
kobe bryant i was not [ __ ] on you it
was just an observation
masked i'm suffering i
am suffering do you know i did these
exercises yesterday
i know i'm supposed to watch caitlyn
jenner baby he stopped saying money
and he started calling me a beast
i think he watches the show well because
he's yeah the first time he came it was
all money money money money
i don't think he knew who i was though
for sure so maybe someone sent him the
clip
probably the second time he came he
stopped saying money he slipped it in a
few times but i felt like he was trying
not
out of reflex yeah but he started
calling me a beast
is there any way you can record these so
i can sound better no
they're right
[Laughter]
do you mind if i uh record you
encouraging me and blast it out no
i can come with a boom and just record
it all
that is funny observation that is kind
of a funny
that is kind of a funny idea
this is our sound guy we're just
capturing
that's pretty funny zach
yeah okay so you exercised twice this
week and i'm eating these [ __ ] meals
and your mom is cooking all this
delicious food
and i'm sitting there eating like
cauliflower
let's see hmm but everything like i ask
you about the food you say it's not that
bad
it's not i mean
i want snacks i want you you don't
understand my whole reward system
for example look at ian taking that deep
chug
oh where were you eating that down real
quick he was taking like a really deep
chug like smoothie or something
thank you i've been chugging the water
there it is
i was waiting for it um i wanna chug
my whole i'm like such an addict i'm
realizing it's been
almost exactly what
well what do you say like that no
because i think it's revealing the real
problem i've known i'm an addict
but you can't just like what do you want
to go cold turkey you know you go cold
turkey you kill people that's how you
kill people
people just like [ __ ] chicken i don't
think you're dying anytime who deserves
fried chicken
me i just start fried chicken's fine
wednesday i deserve fried [ __ ]
chicken
because every time i ask you you're like
no the food is actually not that bad but
i
am so sad no i i genuinely think it's
affecting my mental state because
you look really sad my whole reward
system
is around food and i know that because
every time
that's why i hate saying no because
you're like you want to order and you're
like you get so happy about it
so it's like oh for example after
friday's show you guys all know i'm
notorious like oh let's get
mexican food because it's like i
finished the week but let's find you
something else
then that's a party that's my idea
let's find a different reward cigarettes
no no
and that's not good so would you rather
me smoke or be fat
both are not good for you
which one
by the way i don't want to give you guys
the impression on this i'm not a serious
smoker it's like
either's mom smoke so since she's been
here there's been cigarettes around and
i generally don't smoke but when they're
around i i usually but she smokes like
one a day
no she doesn't well exactly so she used
to
so and then she stopped because my dad
died of
lung cancer yeah so obviously no one
should smoke
of course nobody should smoke but that's
obvious so he she stopped and then
i guess she started to smoke again and i
didn't say anything because i was like
okay well if that if she smokes one a
day but now i see that it's not really
one a day i think she's on vacation
she's just enjoying herself but i'm
gonna have to say something
oh god here comes the smoking big joints
and then ethan started to join her and i
was like okay whatever i'm going to let
you guys have fun i'm not going to say
anything
but now it's like you wake up you go
over cigarettes
and another cigarette it's around i
can't control myself
i have i have bad impulse control when
stuff's around
get a vape get hard live up to the
[ __ ] stop everything
well or just stop everything that's what
do you want i just i i have
no joy a recreational joy in my life
obviously i'm not going to say my life
is joyless because it's not thank you
zach i have no joy in my recreational
joy in my life do you understand
welcome to being an adult that's not
what being adult is
yes it is having nothing to look having
nothing to do
no pleasure no let's find your pleasures
there should be a place i need a
pleasure ela find me one thing that i
like
besides french fries and cigarettes
does anyone have a suggestion um
you know those um those like
wooden ships that you build inside of a
big glass bottle
stop that's not my new hobby what do you
even call that
i don't know how do they do that for
real maybe you should get
get into it that's a rabbit hole i think
i always wondered how they get those
[ __ ] chips in the bottle
piece by piece and you build a [ __ ]
boat that's amazing i mean with peace
and love
i would rather [ __ ] kill the mass
singer yeah
me too do they really i thought are you
[ __ ] with me
you find me a video of someone putting
the boat all i've seen is videos of it
in movies which is why i'm not totally
sure because somebody's seen me i want
to know
i've never seen somebody do it in real
life everyone in the chat is saying
smoke weed we
both don't like it it makes us paranoid
well that yeah we just sucks for you
guys i would rather right
weed is like the worst thing so
we can't do drugs no also i can't do
anything
i can't really do any recreational drugs
including drinking because of the alexa
pro i'm on
i don't even like drinking though
drinking
[Music]
[Laughter]
what about an instrument what about the
picking up the guitar what about what
picking up the guitar right yeah
play some music i love it i'll come over
and give you a lesson i love it when you
play it again zach will give you less
lessons i love your music
zach do you know who i am i'm not that
good at guitar
yes okay but like guitar
i just need a new video game yeah a new
video game
babies i downloaded monster hunter the
new one on switch it's okay
and those games that's getting sucked
what about shopping
i don't like shopping because i'm fat
and nothing fits me so buy
bigger clothes because but no because
then that's an admission that i'm never
going to lose weight
so maybe just a minute i'm not gonna oh
if i admit it can i eat
and that's different see paradox
no you still need to wear something in
the meantime
look what i'm wearing right now
beautiful who deserves fried chicken
yeah no but i'm saying like
trying to find you something you enjoy
like
um someone sent me uh how does those
boats get okay
i wonder how the [ __ ] boat gets in
the damn bottle
there we go i think you're interested i
think we might have just
hit on something here all right nice
okay let's
mute this dumbass all right let's get to
the part he builds
the boat that boat sucks
yeah i've seen him cra i just want to
know the magic i want to know really
impressive
i mean dan who the [ __ ] are you on this
boat
uh wait hang on another one yo this is
okay okay okay here's the thing
yeah it's they don't wait he's got to
put it in the back and then like
seal the glass back wait what the whole
video it's collapsible
oh oh that's interesting that's good
when you pull like a string and the
sails come up and everything
wait why did you know it's like a little
baby one though wow well he probably
skipped ahead in the video
oh yeah because some of them are so
intricate yeah
wow see that's like kind of small the
ones i've seen i don't think okay just
saying
oh that's really cool wow i think you're
into it dude i think you should give it
a shot
in a bottle sorry this is the most
[ __ ] boring hobby i can ever imagine
doing in my life i hate that
like collecting stamp little things like
i don't like having
i'd rather watch the beverly hills
housewives exactly what i've been doing
it's so sad it's pretty entertaining it
is pretty entertaining
but it's like my situation is messed up
because i started with the latest season
so now i go back a season every time
yeah it's like
like the drama like it's continuous but
every time i learn about it backwards
abc's h3h3 video
no that's a word than i am now all right
i'm just making it
that's where you get it wrong that's
good work we were talk we were gonna
talk about caitlyn jenner
okay so back to the mass singer
apparently wendy williams and logan paul
have been on we're going to watch all
this this is the mass singer but uh this
is the worst show ever and here is
caitlyn jenner being the worst first
the worst singer
[Applause]
like he ever he grabbed my glasses out
the door gonna see
the city before i leave i brush my teeth
with a bottle of jack
because when i leave i'm coming
back i'm talking pedicures
[Applause]
awkwardly dancing
so i thought oh this must be edited
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
where they make you feel awkward exactly
that's what i i thought someone was
[ __ ]
kidding
[Applause]
can you make it louder for me but not
the audience yeah
yeah thank you stop making
and these judges that are apparently
comedians are going live
i'd be like what the [ __ ] was that that
was a nightmare
[Music]
like i'm sorry wow that was that was
just that was
that's awful that's uh what the [ __ ]
this is why these shows are the worst
thing ever
yeah that's the worst thing i've ever
seen in my life
oh she's a bad [ __ ] we love her
who's that guy that age that guy's a
comedian right the asian guy
yeah you lose all credentials as a
comedian when you dance to that what's
his name
forgot and zhang yeah
you lose all credentials when you sit
there as a comedian you're like this is
a pop
i mean it's an awkward position because
you want to like go along with it
this is what you do you're on camera
exactly they're phonies they're fakes
this is what you do as a com as a
comedian with integrity
if you had any integrity i wonder if
they still want you to live react to the
show
i'll live tweet i'll be like this shows
sucking sucks
turn this [ __ ] off
[Laughter]
you like that though they're emailing us
they must be like spam mass emailing
people to react right
oh so they didn't mean the compliment
like they're not actually
saying they're not actually a fan what
kind of compliment is that i love the
array of topics
like what she literally said that my
array of topics
it's like the most generic statement
possible that's true
i love the er she goes to like uh yeah
i love the array of topics i should have
said like what like tell me which one
which episode which is your favorite
topic
um let's see the other ones i'm really
curious now because
we should actually do our ad reads right
here now we're
32 minutes into the show oh i'm fun here
sorry all right let's do keeps last time
we did this
they made us do a make good no they
didn't and stop saying that
wait i thought you said that they did
they didn't no
are you saying that because i'm not
supposed to say that no
but we should also just stop discussing
this and just do the [ __ ] wait
what is it so we keep stop bad so i'm
gonna just i'm just gonna do this dry as
possible
because they don't like when i deviate
too much
right don't say anything about what they
like or don't like i like the metaness
okay here we go guys i'm just going to
tell you to you straight
okay two out of three men will
experience some form of hair loss
by the time they're 35 that's just the
fact
damn why you laughing i didn't say i
literally just read the fact why are you
giggling
why why
i think it's because you went like to
zero personality
i'm just doing what they want here we go
is that why you're laughing i am
that's what i'm doing listen two out of
three of you
men out there are going to lose your
[ __ ] hair by the time you're 35
period or ruling some of it not all of
it
but enough all right here we go keeps
offers a simple
stress-free way to keep your hair
convenient virtual doctor consultations
and medication delivered straight to
your door
every three months you don't even have
to leave your house
you sad [ __ ] loser that's me not them
that's what i i mean i know it's kovid
so it's like it makes sense but usually
that's like
you pathetically no you don't ever leave
your house
low cost the treatments start at just
ten dollars per month and keeps offers a
generic version
fascinating discreet
thing well
it's just the way they put generic in
there
it just doesn't it's not it doesn't
sound flattering it's like
treatment starts at ten dollars per
month and keep
offers a generic version
like just don't say generic
but it's the same they mean it's the
same active ingredient it's just a
better price
that's what should you guys know what
generic is
discreet packaging and proven results
so your neighbors don't know you're
going bald that's why they said it in
discrete packaging
or not that but just so they obviously
they could tell you're losing air just
visually but
they don't want you to they don't want
to you may not want to know
that you're insecure about it
that's why discrete packaging but the
results are proven so that's good news
dude they got five stars more than any
of their competitors
prevention is key that's what it's all
about treatment can take four to six
months so don't
wait act fast and let it kick in and
save that beautiful hair
guys we need to get pulling some good
results here so we don't get
so help me out if you're ready to take
action prevent hair loss go to keeps
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash after dark
to receive your first month of treatment
for free
that's k-e-e-p-s dot com
slash after dark to get your first month
free keeps k-e-e-p-s
come on we know how many times everybody
knows how to spell keeps
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash
after dark nice
all right please support our sponsor
thank you we love cubes
i mean it's a great product
we have one more and mobile
love mint mobile
min mobile after years of fine print
contracts and getting ripped off by
big wireless providers if we've learned
anything
is that there's always a catch
but when i first heard about mint mobile
when i fir when
uh when i first heard
that mint mobile offers premium wireless
service starting at just
15 bucks a month i thought hmm
what is the catch but after speaking
with them and using their service
it all made sense
there isn't one no catch
mint mobile secret sauce
why do they write a first person
that always throws me off when they do
that they go
they make me say all this [ __ ] they're
like read this verbatim
i thought what is this
i love mint mobile it's a great service
but here let me get my little stink on
it
but after speaking with them and using
their service it all made sense there
isn't one
mint mobile secret sauce is that they're
the first company to sell wireless
services online only
they cut out the retail stores there's
no crazy overhead costs
and the savings all get passed down to
you in the form
of fat beautiful
savings and a lower bill you know what
it is come on mint mobile
just passes the sweet savings on
directly to you so for people looking
for extra savings mint mobile offers
premium wireless for just fifteen
dollars a month that is a good
[ __ ] deal all plans come with
unlimited talk text
and high-speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g network
use your own phone with any mint mobile
plan
and keep your same phone number along
with your existing contacts if you're
not 100
billion trillion percent satisfied
mobile has you covered with their seven
day money back guarantee
switch to mint mobile and get premium
wireless service starting at just 15
bucks a month so
to get your new wireless plan for just
15 bucks a month and to get the plan
shipped to your door for free
discreetly i'm just kidding
it didn't say discreetly to get it
shipped to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com
h3 that's mintmobile.com h3
cut your wireless bill to 15 a month at
mintmobile.com
h3 thank you mobile all right we did it
we made it through there
you think people gonna complain i'm
doing my best for them i really am
we shall see
i feel like i need a tissue i mean i'm
doing my best
here you know
where were we oh yeah i want to watch
logan paul on the mass singer
we got it the clip is this a grandpa
monster
that's him
let me tell you about this man here
so this was recently march next time i
need this for sponsors
march 31st what was that like was like a
week ago to uh we
a little over 10 days ago oh no i'm a
strawberry how deep did he get
i guess we don't know probably not that
dude i've never actually watched a show
so i don't know the format i
i think some of these are just like
one-off surprise guests
kind of thing like i don't think he was
on a full season of it
[Music]
but i could be wrong i'm not a i'm not a
masked singer stan
[Music]
i'm a [ __ ] blueberry wait i
can't listen i'm saying we'll get
claimed out the [ __ ]
hey let's listen to the last one i did
we just watched the caleb general oh
yeah but she's so she like literally
like there's nothing
there's nothing i know about it yeah oh
but their sinking is like
so done in the studio and perfected and
everything
in this case
how's he singing through that suit and
dancing and [ __ ]
this [ __ ] is so funny bro have you ever
been in the audience that maybe outside
the super bowl and been like this
[Laughter]
the audience is probably paid paid
that's they do that all the time are
they really they have to come for free
probably
those kind of songs or do you think they
have a paid section
like competition shows like this pay at
least a portion of their audience to be
there
wow i don't know
[Music]
i can't i can't hear anything dan it's
so
quiet
their very first crush
[Applause]
whose grandpa monster had a crush on
when he was a kid
men in black bring out the wall what am
i watching
what the [ __ ] is this
what is this took the whole brick wall
and turn it around
all right can we get on with it please
these people don't know who logan paul
is do they
like yeah unlikely like i said i've seen
a lot of these clips where they reveal
people and it's like
who they they always go oh yeah look who
they're guessing
jack black are you [ __ ] serious i
actually have a career
conor mcgregor another very close friend
of the rocks
and dances just like that is jack black
he's like nope way less famous pretty
good okay
i want to hear from you nicole so we saw
the dog
which was a boxer wait he saying he's
friends with the rock because he did a
video with him once like
[ __ ] like five years ago oh
that's what it was wait he didn't unmask
himself what kind of [ __ ] video is
this yo
you have to watch the show to see the
big reveal wait there's no unmasking
no it's a separate video oh my god
let me tell you about banana this is a
lot for me alright well send me that one
i gotta see the big reveal where
everyone pretends to know who he is
i'm so excited all right
probably the only thing that the people
that watch the show would know him from
is the suicide forest all right
like that's the only thing that was like
mainstream enough we don't say the s
word though dan oh i'm sorry
i think it's funny he was singing bad
reputation bro what is with the audio
levels i'm dying here it's like
zach is so loud
[Applause]
is it conor mcgregor is it jack black is
it uh bruce willis
[Laughter]
all right [ __ ] today with the rock
poster
dude they don't know who he is there's
no way yeah i think you're right
apparently one of them guessed jake paul
see what we're saying
internet personality girl
this is the worst thing ever
all of a sudden oh internet pusher boxer
not jake paul
i love that they can't escape yeah well
your brother is apparently a r
is a uh wait to hear the story about his
brother
that then oh that's a good sound bite
not
jake paul yeah they're gonna be saying
that constantly
talk about the next story
wouldn't it be more realistic if they
just were like
i i honestly don't know who you are
wouldn't that be fun
but thanks for letting me know there's
no way if they're all like
we all literally have no idea where we
are collectively
i love that i want to do that show
and you said wendy was on her i don't
really give a [ __ ] i'd rather just watch
her fart
yeah they're using a fake audience
because of kovit for the last
yeah someone just sent that to me i just
looked it up yeah so they're because of
covid
i'm using a fake studio audience which
is uh
so there isn't really audience there or
what no there's no audience really there
is it just b-roll
people are saying that's from season one
they're using clips
like reused footage wow that's so weird
that's a no that's a show i want to be
involved in
i could such social distance them at
least
instead of just reusing people cheering
because they're not cheering for you
it's fake
it's so weird i mean what the [ __ ] how
are you supposed to feel as the
competitor
watching people who are not there cheer
for you
it's fake
what's with your background maybe what
is that rough riders
dmx um oh i see you're doing it
rest in peace right
wow you know it's almost like an insult
to the dearly
shout departed to his family
yeah uh we got will i am is back
is the window clip good because some
people are you guys want wendy spamming
that it wasn't that good
not that good how good could it be yeah
barely move yeah
but i do want to talk about wendy
because this is yeah yeah let's talk
about wendy williams here let me go
target
okay so far gate as you guys know wendy
williams notoriously farting on the air
we've asked a ton of people to make
their best fart
wendy william fart remixes and a lot of
people delivered
so first of all let's just go a little
walk through uh
uh memory lane here with the most
classic
27 years old you're old enough to
understand political correctness in the
times that we live now
she's trying to squeeze it out just slap
people on the booty yeah of course
he probably knows it's not right from a
man to a woman or a woman to a man
but you can't even do that locker room
thing that cop wasn't playing that
i mean you're lucky you only got better
yeah it you can't even hear well go
ahead zach
that's the sound that's the real
isolated sound
now coming up next just a whole
illustrious history i'll quickly go over
for you guys
is that now she burps and farts at the
same time which is a rare
it's a rare phenomenon but to do it on
television is is uh
five new boyfriends fantastic we haven't
caught anybody coming out of the house
yet but you know
just a matter of time she's not lonely
i apologize i apologize oh
oh she uploaded it it's just called
monday march 15.
interesting did i play it in a sec
clean really clean
number three we have what we can only
refer to as a far
a snort and a burp um
enjoy here we go hot topics so i just
slow down
it's okay
[Laughter]
anything like i'm back in the game
immediately
immediately and then the virus happened
so i just slow down it's okay
oh they were trying to save her
with the producer to try to save
[Laughter]
was she divorced recently i think that's
what i'm understanding just from this
clip
get us did you have a nice weekend it
was cool i'm sorry
the whole thing like like not just the
wolf but like i want it all
right
what is that
play the whole thing like all the way
through
[Laughter]
was she coughing was she trying to cover
it up
[Laughter]
oh that was a good one wow
so there was actually so those were the
three sound bites we
entered there's been new ones actually i
i feel sad that the um
musicians weren't able to use these new
resources
wait have i heard over them these are
all brand new
i have three new ones dude
let's see what do we do next we're gonna
get some moves so gonna stand up
can you guys hit the music for me
play that hit me with that
wait again
you know what deep breathing is very
important exactly what you're saying
yeah it helps you laugh
what do we do next we're going to get
some moves so going to stand up
can you guys hit the music so loud
like it's like too far right into the
mind
like what's your explanation for that
down like that it must have
not loud i'm not
entirely sure it's a fart
when she's standing up yeah play the
clip again okay
okay you know what deep breathing is
very important i can get it exactly what
you're saying yeah it helps you
what do we do next we're gonna get some
moves so gonna stand up
can you guys i think
i think it's her saying all right what
no
we're gonna go inside out of her mouth
all right all right
all right zach
you used to play the sound backwards
how's that mouth sound hit the music for
me let's do this i've seen a lot of
people in the chat agreeing
what yeah i don't see that okay you know
what deep breathing is very important
exactly what you're saying yeah it helps
what do we do next we're going to get
some moves so going to stand up
all right can you guys even see your
mouth move a little bit oh maybe she
goes
yep sorry ethan i just got to point
something out you actually named the
note right
you said yeah it's an e sharp but that's
also an
f so right i was going to say there's no
such thing as
yeah yeah so you you
in some way you did nail it yeah oh
because it's an f
it actually is gotcha gotcha
everybody knows ethan has perfect pitch
so did you know that um
here's a trivia question for you did you
know that wendy william farts an
f incidentally the first letter of
fart of course it's an f
there's a lot of disagreement like
there's back and forth some people are
saying it's a fart
some people are agreeing that i kind of
agreed that maybe
i feel like you see her mouth move a
little bit let's go back
let's go back but deep breathing is very
important exactly what you're saying
yeah it helps you laugh
what do we do next we're going to get
some moves so
perfectly in unison with that noise i
wish i could go back
it's like uh mm-hmm me pitching up see
if we can
okay so going to stand up can you guys
hit
it's who makes that sound okay zoom in
close here we go
here we go okay ready so going to stand
up
can you guys hit the music why does her
mouth just go mom
i mean i don't know i mean we've seen
lots of evidence in the other windy
videos that she
makes strange guttural noises all the
time so it's not
so people think this is not a fart
intrigued by that
yeah let's throw it to the pole because
we you know ian can you straw pull us
please
thank you i guess i can see your point i
hate to be the party pooper but it's
just
i think she's just um making like a
glitch zach can you slow it down
and see what it sounds like
slow down and enhance
people are saying she had a drug problem
that messed with her bowel sounds
yeah they're saying really it could mess
with your bowel sounds what the [ __ ]
what is that
how do you what with the digestive
system
i've heard of i've heard of something
like that before your farts sound
different
like no you just like the controlling of
it all as well
i think she may have a condition too i
agree yeah
i mean look wendy williams just kind of
i don't feel
i don't feel bad making fun of her
because that's what she does for a
living and she's like talk so much [ __ ]
oh yeah she made fun of i don't know
what came in his cleft lip
she's done a bunch of messed up [ __ ]
yeah i don't like her at all so
i have no problem poking fun at her
farting
issues um you know
just don't put a mic next to your
[ __ ]
okay send me the butt the fact that you
you hear it so close maybe it doesn't
mean that it's the mouth
that's that's what i was like why is it
because it's like
yeah oh we have a stream labs poll going
oh cool
wait what does that mean stream labs
like people are voting in the chat
instead so everybody can vote well then
how do i see the room
uh i don't know i didn't set this up
what is happening
or who's doing it i just see like vote
but yeah i guess it's only me that i can
screenshot it
um well what are the what's the results
so everybody can vote on this you don't
have to be a member
no i think you do have to be a member
that's why you don't usually do it this
way
yeah we should do the straw poll but
people are saying
fart or
all what does all right mean that that's
what she's saying oh she's saying all
right you think
all right she's saying all right oh i
didn't even know
no there was a word being all right oh
so people
overwhelmingly don't think it's a fart
let me listen again closely
turn it up for me dad important i can
get exactly what you're saying yeah
what do we do next we're going to get
some moves so going to stand up
can you guys hit the music for how do
you hear all right
it's literally just a beep okay whatever
we think there's she's not enough
sometimes something can come out weird
you know i'm like
all right all right it came out weird
all right when she's off because she was
standing up exactly she's
exerting herself out she said okay all
right so we're we're
we're there's [ __ ] there is debate let's
just put this one as an alleged fart
did she have vocal farts maybe she talks
out of her ass i mean
that's the only way she has a condition
after all
[Music]
so this one um
this one i think i saw yeah
me after i get in the face with a
dodgeball and everyone turns to me and
as if i'm okay
this is something i saw there's so many
buried moments
[Laughter]
different species that's wild man
i don't know i feel like all these clips
are making me like her because it's like
so ridiculous well hey it's so silly
so maybe so maybe yeah i like that you
that i mean you know
everything's open to interpretation
[Laughter]
i mean she's she's interesting she's
just a sound machine
yeah remember that guy from uh a police
academy what was the goofy
movie there's the black guy that could
make every sound winslow
uh something that's sorry michael
winslow michael
he's like oh wendy williams is the one
person
here's the newest one she spills tea on
herself
and makes a great sound
[Music]
[Applause]
it's okay it's okay
[Laughter]
like a baby it's like baby mario
[Applause]
it's okay it's okay it's okay
well those are all the great ones we
found
but these were just about the farts so
we've got
quite a few here
of original content from some really
talented people
we actually got so many and it would be
we can't play them all so
if we don't get to yours i apologize we
have to pair it down
we have one two three we have a lot of
them this is after paring it down like
we got
this is the top of the probably this is
a cream of the crop 60 or 70
submissions so oscar wilde he's a famous
cj right
150 000 followers yeah that's a lot
so shout out to oscar wilde time to get
wild
you can't just slap people on the booty
of course he probably knows it's not
right from a man to a woman or a woman
to a man but you can't even do that
thing that cop wasn't playing that i
mean i mean
i mean i mean i mean i mean
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah i think he's playing on pads that's
cool
shout out to his family i want us to
choose i want us to pick a winner
okay and we gotta and then the winner we
should make a custom trophy of like uh
okay a fart cloud coming out of wendy
william or something
but we'll do something special for the
winner
alex preston is up next um
now alex preston this guy
okay is this the actual file or my uh
a b yes this is it this is the final
alex preston's also a famous musician
isn't he i don't think that that's the
final that looks like a little preview
yeah this doesn't look like the final
then i thought it was
dan was this the one you updated and and
the other day
yeah i thought we fixed this skip to the
next one okay alex preston
is a apparent this guy is a
serious contender um oh american idol
oh he was a fun or mommy
finalist american idol finalist
either we watch all right i guess we
can't probably
watch his performance he's got a
wikipedia plays guitar
wow legit yeah so he made an entry
um
this this one this is like the making of
well yeah he kept sending
teases on twitter okay um but it doesn't
appear that we have the final
version ready do we
well we'll update it i'm looking for it
right now just skip it for now
okay we'll come back to alex beats by
berm beats by berm is coming in
theater stairway shouting for us what do
you think
okay big big something
uh berm beats by berm here we go
[Music]
[Music]
pretty dirty i like that
i like the ones where you can really
feel and appreciate the fart
yeah burps you know what i mean um did
you guys find it
yeah okay great so here is the
alex i'm replacing it right now oh okay
alex preston i was following his
development on twitter and i was always
very very very impressed by it so i'm
very excited to share alex preston's
with you guys
[Music]
um
okay here we go
[Music]
several different ways i mean what is
going on
[Music]
yes
wendy williams am i right
[Applause]
i tell you if you talk enough you know
you get the
air right my so first this this
one is my favorite so far and he really
lets the farts
take center stage exactly and there's
this one moment where the fart rips so
loud and hard
right when it drops
[Music]
yeah the fart sounds musical so that's
alex preston who i think is
is a strong entry garcia
up next do we have any information about
joseph's lightning
he's just a man that loves the farts
it's a man that loves with a little bit
of williams
oh yeah okay you guys aren't gonna
believe this
what is going on with her
i don't know
[Music]
come on good people that doesn't get
better than that
wendy williams third part
remember it's not wednesday it's wendy
williams
third fart
third part
what the [ __ ] was this
okay whoops so that was a really fun the
farting
took backseat i kind of disagree it was
less farting but
the the farts that were there were very
strategic really
i mean there was a fart there that
really blew me away yeah
yeah yeah when it came in it was like it
was with a lot of intent
a lot of purpose okay so let's elevate
let's sell it i mean i agree that one
was really good that was that's a
contender as well so here let me
highlight the contenders and then we can
have a we can vote them off the island
can you guys highlight joseph and alex
for me okay moving on we've got
uh bogues this one comes from soundcloud
oh you know these people are serious in
soundcloud
so i'm calling out all musicians who are
really good at making digital music to
you know i want that beat
i know there's like a dope ass beat
somewhere there between all the sounds
[Music]
to slow down it's okay
[Music]
not to be controversial but i think
[Music]
what the [ __ ] was this i'm not quite
sure what i heard
[Music]
house part yeah party [ __ ] like you
could
you could throw that on at a house party
and no one will no one would
no one would even notice that they were
listening that wendy williams farting
that was [ __ ] awesome that was really
good wow shout out to bogues bugs
damn there's there's a lot of
of yeah highlighter they're all so
different how we're going to pick one
we're going to have to look at this one
that's like a different personality
you have to pick which one you love more
start um
ian start putting together a straw poll
now all right with the
ones that we were uh selecting as uh
potential winners thank you uh tom
hale coming from tom hill i mean
[Music]
a little more laid back
this is like you could spit a rhyme yeah
[Music]
yeah we need drake on
is it just this it's just two minutes
long
hey hey yo wendy williams
[Music]
yo i've got to get someone on this beat
that's the next round if you're out
there if you if you rap
rip this and uh wrap over the speed and
send it to us nice beat but
it's too long two minutes thank you tom
hale go ahead
i like how he used as the hi-hat to use
the farts
yeah no it was it that was always clever
that was a strong entry i don't think it
rises
to quite to the top of the wait let me
hear that yeah
very good though it's good oh yeah
right yeah no it's good integration of
the farts it's
very good i mean listen it rose to the
top of the pile
thumbnail everybody that we're playing
has already
is a cut above so this one comes from
garuge but a v instead of a u griff
um caught anybody coming out of the
house
his name is grvs 80808 windy
here we go fart beat
just a matter of time she's not lonely
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
change my costume
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i have never farted once on this show as
a matter of fact
i would have definitely been back
because farts are always
[Music]
wow nice wow strong
yes strong entry yeah i like how you
picked it
for the melody he pitched the farts as
the melody yeah absolutely yeah
man this is a tough one so it seems like
fun
this is hard because we have like four
top contenders
is there any you think you think we
could immediately immediately
well did you guys like alex preston i
thought his was so good
yeah no i think i think alex
[Music]
how do we decide the winner here we're
going to put it to a vote right
but i'm going to have to play you know
what i'm going to do i'm going to play a
bit of it to remind you play a bit of
each one
yeah okay so we have four or we have
five
finalists wow
okay so we've got a straw that's what it
is you know okay
so is it does everyone have the straw
poll or we that was
oh yeah that was it okay no wait we need
to figure out i think you need to play
him one more time
and then we'll put it up so everyone can
remember which is which
i think okay this is out write down your
vote
alex preston this is alex preston
[Music]
well-conceived alex preston
um up next a little reminder is joseph
garcia joseph garcia
let's lighten it up with a little bit of
williams
ripping ass on tv are you ready zach
oh yeah okay you guys aren't going to
believe this
come on good people that doesn't get
better than that
so there was one where i said wendy this
one where i said it didn't have enough
farts but you guys disagreed so let me
listen yeah
yeah this one i feel like incorporated
the parts into the beat a little bit
less
but really hit you with some powerful
moments throughout so
i don't know
[Music]
uh like there's no more guns i apologize
that's joseph garcia joseph garcia
everyone
okay next we have bogues bows music
so i'm calling out all musicians who are
[Music]
[Music]
not to be controversial but i think
that's a supernatural
i don't know that one's strong it's
strong that's strong
bogues everybody and finally we have um
grouch with a v instead of a u i'm
i'm assuming that's anybody kind of trap
but you know
yeah just a matter of time
[Music]
all right so so what about the guy on
twitter we
that was alex preston he was the guy on
twitter
there was another one i think oh oscar i
don't think oscar wilde made the cut
oh did he i don't know no i wasn't sure
i mean
you can't just slap people on the booty
of course he probably knows you could
throw it off
but you can't even do that thing that
cop wasn't playing that i mean
i mean i mean points for doing it live i
think yeah points for doing it live i
agree
i agree i mean technically i think his
show of skill is the best
i didn't hear enough
[Music]
yeah yeah incredible we love that
all right well it's in your guys's hands
now i'm not going to say who i'm going
to vote for
i don't want to but somebody but you you
have an opinion
i do have an opinion okay so we'll share
that after we uh after we post the poll
all right
i'll pin it as well so it's the message
in the chat
i think this yeah me too i'm voting the
same one
interesting all right let's see what the
who's the f
who is the quan let's probably give it
give it another
30 seconds queen of wendy farts
this is a huge minute here what are you
guys feeling so we're gonna make them
like
we're gonna make them a trophy trophy
yeah wow of wendy william i think it
should be her squatting to the side or
something
bogues coming in showing strong strength
here
but uh initial it's just one dot too
many yeah
just one dump not all the numbers are
coming in
oh my goodness
we have an overwhelming winner big
massive dumps
give it a little bit more time it's only
four thousand votes there's about
50 000 people watching dumps but yeah i
don't think that that that
that's both that's a lot to overcome
that's bugs and i'll be honest
that's who i voted
is this guy somebody on soundcloud it
has um g only
500 plays no so i have his information
reach out to him you guys have his email
we're gonna have to put together a nice
package for him
so i'm calling out musicians who are
really good at making digital music to
you know putting the length i want to be
in the
i know there's like a dope ass beat
somewhere there between all this
you know what i do for this guy bugs i'm
going to put his instagram handle
and his spotify his spotify argus name
is bogues he's
bows catch my name on instagram he's
bogue's music we'll put that in the
description see if you want to check out
more of the bogue's bomb
bogus music but here it is the winner
[Music]
to slow down it's okay
one more time thank you for one more
spin baby
[Music]
right now
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
i'm not quite sure what i heard
so there it is bugs ladies and gentlemen
wow
a stiff competition my goodness they
were all so good though
they're also good and honestly there
were there were some pretty good ones
too that we didn't even
get to but it was just thank you
everybody
it was probably about 50 60 ish
submissions
no thank you guys i'm flattered and
farted
flat flattered flattered sounds like the
sound of a fart makes like yeah
flattered oh it's like my butthole's
flooded
flattering fluttered fluttering
my anal my anal my cheeks are fluttering
and i'm also flattered um speaking of
farting
um there was a fart gate 3.0
people are saying now i'm in the middle
of a fart gate eli i don't know if
you've seen this you can tell me i don't
think i farted but
alex preston said thanks for the love
congrats
yeah well deserved one you i thought you
know what alex i saw yours on twitter
honestly i think uh
alex's was like too beautiful it was a
it was a symphony it was really
beautiful like i said i could present
that to the queen
you know what i mean your majesty i
present you
yeah thank you alex that was a beautiful
piece yeah
yeah he died if you all didn't hear
about it don't want to be disrespectful
as apparently he's was a
prince yeah i thought i'd give him a
[ __ ]
he's from england i'm a man i wake up i
bow to no man
um yeah tell me if i farted
so
i don't think i would rip ass like that
you know what
so it could easily be the chair thank
you
it's too loud it's too loud if i would
have farted that loud i would have
acknowledged it right
i wouldn't just try to pretend i'm not
wondering there would have been a
reaction
yeah so
it's like yeah no
i i i uh i deny
i denied and i did not i think it's a
fart
whoa what
well i analyze the audio okay what'd you
find
[ __ ] forensic audio fbi looking at
the sound wave
and from what i've seen from other fart
sound waves
so far what exactly are your credentials
for analyzing sound waves
uh he's the sound guy he's the sound
analyze sound boy incorporated
when was that shot is that it was like
last week or two weeks ago
okay because why do you think i would
you would first of all to pick up that
loud i would have to
are you about to smell my chair no i
think you were using this cheap
amazon chair oh no it does make noises
no
it was not true no because i see that
one being right there
yeah it's just set off to the side you
know i always i would if these chairs
are
really loud so it wasn't this car chair
so it's a it's the chair that you're
currently sitting in ethan just wanting
to rock make a noise rock back and forth
let's see
i'm not saying it's the chair i don't
know this is mike dan listen it's a
judgment-free zone man
this is the fart that loud
the i would have to be so loud that damn
would have heard it
everybody would have heard it and i'm
not just going to carry on like nothing
happened like wendy williams so
you know what i mean so don't
necessarily carry on like nothing
happened didn't you fart i mean
sometimes
yeah i don't know man
here send this to james charles
oh no too old oh no
i didn't deny it i don't have to tell
you i i i would own it i just knew that
was coming
i mean you've heard me far more than
anyone eli you can tell me you have
parted that loud oh well there you go
and my life yeah usually you
do react to it like of course i'm not
going to rip
ass and be like so anyway i have a case
to be mandatory
you will change this analyzer go ahead
you include sound waves
no no no you were transitioning diets
during when this far it happened
you think i didn't notice yeah i think
it just slipped out
i think you farted it's okay everyone
farts everyone poops
i know it's okay zach i know it's okay
um are you you're telling me that my
i've lost control of my
of my sphincter muscle i mean you know
diets do that man
not me you're hey dude you're the one
that [ __ ] on a [ __ ] lawn
that's not okay okay it's okay
i wouldn't but then how sure are you
that he wasn't sitting on the cheap
chair because i'm sure no no no no
really no
dan thinks it's a fart so he's one
because that cheap chair makes a ton of
noise yeah he would be doing it all
throughout the episode like
it would it wouldn't
exactly well here's the thing you also
had a mic dude yeah
here's the thing though my mic unlike
everybody else
stays muted when i'm not speaking
because i have access to no because i
have access to the sound board so listen
i was about to stick up for you and now
you're throwing
shade my way okay well the truth is all
that matters dan so
because pretty much everybody on the
zoom call a b
zack and ian they're open mic
the whole time seriously well actually
ian has the switch that's why
you always hear ian turn on his mic but
zach and a b open mics so so
really you guys have open mics and
you're gonna talk about me farting
wait what are we saying they're saying
it could be anyone coming from anyone
really i'm just wearing it down to
zlatan maybe they come from somewhere
else
i mean possibly because they're they're
on the call their mics are open so the
only reason i have the sound board here
because i'm on camera okay i i've
i have farted during the show but
when i when i hear a fart coming i
always mute my mic except this
for you to bring up the loss of the
sphincter muscle
is something that would only have to
come from a piercing experience
i have never lost control of my
sphincter muscle to the point where a
fart just
leaks out and surprises me zach if
that's happened
it's because you've experienced it and
if i can go back even further i think
you experienced it that day
and you did it in your mind and now and
now
excuse me i'm not done now you're
sitting there
talking about farting's okay zach i
think you're talking to yourself
case closed my [ __ ] has
i have a case to make oh yeah i i don't
think zack is a good liar
so i feel like if it was him we would
have known already
but abraham is still being raised
remember who scored a kai on this heist
on the sociopathy
right was a b he's
being oddly quiet maybe did you fart
it wasn't me no i did not fight a b win
i feel like a b would be a good liar
because of his sociopathy
i don't know though because absolutely
number one so baby's always willing to
fall on a grenade for you you know what
i mean like he's not the first one
yeah that's true that's true like she
could
that's what a sociopath would say
because now you're trying to admit to it
even though you now you know nobody's
going to take your confession seriously
because you
because everyone just said you'd fall in
a grenade for me
ethan i'm trying to help you out here
you want to say come out of my ass or
not
this is like jfk who shot jfk we'll
never know the grassy knoll
my ass is a grassy knoll can you try
rocking in your chair
my ass is the grassy knoll with the pear
and like the huge plane to grasp my ass
as a grassy knoll
all right let's move on i think we've
debated this one yeah
we shall never know the truth yeah yeah
yeah yeah
you guys want to hear about this let me
get a taste
we've got um what do you want to talk
about next stila we've got williams new
invention
yes or jake paul is a r word
essay jake ball essay
i don't oh man our bad baby geez we have
a lot
it's gonna be one of those episodes huh
another four hour episode
yeah where i don't get to order mexican
food and that's like so [ __ ] sad to
me
hmm what about going for a drive getting
coffee
that's fine but it's you know
miniature boat building i think we need
to start smoking weed
and that's what's up will ruin my life
i hate this it's a phenomenal sounds
like what everyone does i know but i
hate it and every time i go oh maybe i
should try it again
i do it and i hate it i just i hate it
i literally regret it every time i do it
i'm like wow this is the worst thing
decision i've ever made
what do you feel like when you're on it
you just get paranoid anxious
anxious
you know but maybe we've changed no we
haven't that's what i always tell myself
maybe it's been long that's what i told
myself and i always hate it
overrated drug [ __ ] fried chicken
all right let's talk about will i am
because i like this one will i
am has a track record of horrible
inventions this guy must be bleeding
money
because he invests a lot of money and
what is just like the
most um i am here with william
it's the worst like if you go back we
made a h3 video about um
some of his horrible so long ago long
time ago but here was one of his first
ones
and uh he this one was called the pulse
it's a watch
okay this is great it can apparently
determine if the caller has a good vibe
or a bad
vibe and you can decide not to answer
the
so you can not answer the bad vibes so
if ethan's calling
bad vibing it's red and i can decide
like oh he's bad vibing so i don't want
to answer
which i thought was the funniest concept
because it's basically when like someone
calls you with help or they're in a bad
mood or like something bad happen you're
like [ __ ] bad vibes bro
oh someone died or my car's broke down
it's like
[ __ ] that it's like in theory it's
actually just a really like uh
sadistic it's like maybe just don't
answer anybody then
oh he's in good mood because who's gonna
call you with a bad vibe no one's gonna
like rarely someone calls you angry that
you [ __ ] up right like
i don't i mean i don't know i'm not i
don't get angry calls very often
i think it used to be more but people
text now
more like people almost never call can
we analyze the text before we accept
them
well here let's let's listen to uh will
i am i am to showcase off
his pulse you don't you don't call a
smartwatch a connected device
well it's not a watch one it's a device
on your wrist called the pulse
it's not a watch because watches don't
have sim cards it's a
new paradigm a new category called
a pulse some cool features like vibe the
vibe is a
is this is was this before the smart or
like the
apple watch um i think smart watches
were already is
it's not a watch also he's got a feather
in his cap like bro what are you robin
hood
who puts a feather in the cap will i
am is such a weird [ __ ] dude man
i love i mean with peace and love you
know it's possible you don't call us
apple watch came out two years later
mm-hmm he's ahead of the
but there were but there were things
like that already in the market
yeah yeah samsung did they have a sim
card in them
oh good question what's not knowledge
that seems to be what i bet you will
like thinks that uh
apple stole the idea from him
knowledge smartwatch oh a connected
device what
do you like it's offended well it's not
a watch it's not a watch first of all
[ __ ] an idiot it's your research okay
despite it going on your wrist and
telling the time you [ __ ]
i've reacted to this video on h3 man
it's crazy
it's a device on your wrist called the
pulse um
it's not a watch because watches don't
have sim cards it's a
new paradigm a new category called
a pulse some cool features like vibe the
vibe is an
app that where that's baked into the os
the vibe can plug into if you choose to
your call
so you could i could record my speech
when i'm speaking so
here's like you were talking about
earlier it hears kind of the tone it
analyzes your voice your mood
it kind of can help you yeah my mom
could follow my vibe
and check up on me like are you stressed
what's wrong with you
can you imagine is everything okay i see
that you're stressed or ma you're happy
what's going on
so you share your vibe with folks um and
more importantly say for example you're
working
and someone calls you with a bad vibe
why do you want to enter a bed by paul
i love that i got pieces i love that why
do you want to answer a bad vibe call
good point i need your help with surgeon
bad vibe your dad is sick your dad just
had a heart attack bad vibe he's
awesome right now look at that i love
that bad vibe call
i got peas is a band i'm in and this
thing i've been working on for two years
is a band i'm wearing
whoa check that out two years down the
drain
that was this that was his first
adventure called the pulse
i guess he kind of what i got i guess
looking back on it he was kind of
ahead of the game but the product was so
bad
the pulse i mean the vibe
there was a i'm trying to remember there
was a invention
that we i have all of them here we were
waiting on not of him
oh but they emailed me that they're
finally ready to ship the product and
then i
messaged you guys if you won't still
want it wasn't the big helmet the covet
helmet
is that what it is yeah yeah we wore
that we had ian wear that
no something uh
i'll try to remember so also
okay and then his next uh invention
we're leading up to the newest invention
i thought he was done inventing but i'm
just trying to bring you guys up to date
but he's not done inventing and his
newest is his best this is the will i am
backpack coming up next here we got to
show you guys this
the the backpack that you're rocking
this this is gnarly there's speakers
pumped in there this is you you
mentioned though
it's going to be able to talk to the
pulse as well right or are there smart
devices
um you know just bluetooth sound and
power
so like apple has their ecosystem you've
got your like
full-on body ecosystem going on here
with the pulse
wearable ecosystem yeah exactly
yeah bro can you imagine someone
cruising around these
giant speakers like what do you want oh
it was the hush me
what was the hush me i have no idea
google hush me somebody who were trying
to buy it a speech privacy mask
oh i think it's if you want to oh
you're right oh we made a whole video on
the hush me
wait they're ready to ship yeah it was a
speech privacy match
right so if you want to talk on the
phone in public you put this thing on
send me the video so yeah we made a
whole video about the hush me
so if you want they're ready to send us
your products
of course i want to hush me yeah
this was the video another one we made a
whole h3 video on
unrelated to will i am but they had this
really good launch
look at this [ __ ] they had a launch
video that was so funny
and someone can find that their website
doesn't appear to be working
but it covers your mouth so you can talk
in public
and private i don't know how that works
look at this guy
yeah oh kickstarter
okay send me the video if you find it
anyway well i am
next up has the um
god he's a lot of inventions the power
a jacket that will charge the pulse when
the sleeves are down
holy [ __ ] so the pulse you have to plug
in at night but this jacket
charges it so he's selling the whole
pulse head to toe so we we've created a
jacket
and components for the jacket for other
fashion houses to design around
our components so that when the sleeve
touches
the watch you have four days tuck three
wait wait wait wait wait wait so you're
saying
your sleeve will be able to charge or
power the watch
yeah yeah with with this fashion line
that you're that you're going use
he's such a bad spokesman for the prada
so we have jackets
give you three days talking why can't we
have jackets that power the device
why can't you wear power holy what power
we need to do pal where because you wear
your power what how about that little
word play
how about it everything everything he
advanced is just around work but
uh the dial watch i remember this one
was really good this came
later separate event let's see
it's called the dial and what powers the
doll is
an amazing um
i wouldn't even know what to call her
but her name is anita and it's this
interface to not only the world's
information but
my personal best experience is the world
of music
anita appears to be a program similar to
siri
with a focus on having a chat but be
careful a dodgy wi-fi connection and
even its master struggles to find the
right words to say
let's have a conversation sounds natural
let's talk about music
dude how lonely are you what are you
doing let's talk about music
okay but is it not working no no it's
not working
i feel like eating sushi seems a bit of
a one-way conversation to me
yo there was one hit like glasses or
something did you guys ever find
something like he's done it all
he made some stink steampunk sunglasses
right
it was something like that yeah because
yeah no it was wild
yeah um here is the hush me by the way
speaking of worst
invention then i replied with you on the
email too
do we want one yeah let's go no audio
dan
is there nothing changed are you sure
there's audio on this video
um it's the hush me you're not supposed
to hear it
here let me click just some random [ __ ]
oh okay what happened to their video
because
there's no audio i don't know they don't
believe in sound
oh it's provided by the installation of
audio on the front
video idiots the device has two modes
passive and active the passive voice
muffling mode is provided by these
they got muted for uh
that's exactly what happened prevent
your voice from spreading so you put
this thing
over your mouth the other hand keep the
external noise from getting into the
microphone
so good personality if i saw someone
like this i think there
like can you move his mouth a single
word
which you've pronounced while wearing
the mask
the active voice mask is the worst this
is their marketing manager
yeah let's buy this because there's no
way if you
there's nothing you can put over your
mouth that will i think everyone will
still hear everything around you
like
this well i don't know if you can buy it
but they
offered to send this one oh you can buy
i'll buy it
buy that right now buy it 300 bucks
i'll take 10. yeah let's definitely buy
that
okay but this is not associated with
well i am in the meantime
to his new did you guys find the
steampunk glasses
i'd search will i am steampunk glasses
and nothing's coming up so
i i don't know what the the work the key
word is for it
well regard this his new 300
super mask pronounced super but it's
spelled with an
x so it's like super mask
um it's his latest invention everything
he makes is like super overpriced by the
way
it's a three hundred dollar mask
ela you don't have to buy it now okay he
looks like filling in her credit card
information
it's not that urgent
[Laughter]
i'm so excited yeah damn dank can buy it
we are doing a show here right right
never seen you so excited to buy
something
all right here's the zooper mask
[Music]
[Music]
oh i probably can't hear the music eh
so i mean it's a mask
and it costs two hundred dollars
and what is special about it she says
superheroes wear masks
knowledge it has knowledge it has
bluetooth
yes but what do you need it's a speaker
it's a headphone
his ears pop out the side though it has
attachments that you can
put yeah it's got little buds that you
plug in there you see that
oh this is for those that don't follow
you know he would you know william was
praying for kova to get worse he's like
god if this thing goes away my mask is
[ __ ]
uh i'm gonna lose another 100 million
dollars say hello to the future
oh we got filtration tell me more
built-in noise cancellation
no seven hour battery life you don't
even need a jacket to charge it
it seems like a lot i don't know
you know what i mean it seems like a lot
i'm not sure i need all those
technologies combined
300 bucks i mean
oh look at that you have one no i don't
but this is this is a five dollar amazon
mask
you have hepa filters yeah it has
filters
oh but also yeah but you are a follower
yeah yeah yeah i'm like but why would
you want your
headphones like not separated from the
mask you can take the mask off
it's like i love these headphones but i
have to wear the super [ __ ] mask when
i'm at home
that's a great point well it's will i am
everything he made
doesn't make sense i would kill to watch
him talk about it i guess you gotta
appreciate the hustle
i appreciate the hustle the guys the
poor guy's gonna bankrupt himself yeah
these inventions i gotta let you know
i'm seeing a decent amount of people in
the chat saying that they like it
they like the mask i mean bro
i'm just i'm reporting what i'm saying
that's the i mean okay
okay i don't know why but okay
it's important to note that for 300 it's
not uh safe
either there's a bunch of warnings about
how it's not uh approved
at the bottom of the website it's okay
it's okay
it's okay yeah uh the buy button doesn't
work
it's okay oh it's sold out oh well
sorry to tell you guys it's sold out i
know we tried to buy one and
it was already all gone oh well what the
[ __ ] drop one what do i
have dropped one right now yeah why am i
talking [ __ ] he's making money
we probably sold like five of them he's
trying to do it like a hypebeast thing
where they have small jobs
yeah i can't imagine too many people too
much to demand for these
people like it i mean just i mean not
everybody but i'm
i'm just saying i am seeing feedback
that it's like let's see here let me
read you some fab
some uh details
it's a joint venture between william and
honeywell
that's a reputable company actually yeah
yadda yadda blah blah
oh here's some warnings about device the
warnings sound funny let's see
you guys ready not a medical device not
a respirator it is not n95
it is not a surgical mask and can't be
used in a clinical setting i mean for
that much money it should at least be
something
it should be n95 yo
um can you imagine your doctor showing
up in this cannot be used in a clinical
set
and i'll determine that it is not a
personal protective equipment and does
not meet the professional standard of
health cares
it's not fda approved does not replace
cdc
uh the product has been authorized
so i saw something about seizures
um
it says this product is not intended for
medical use in
in a high infection risk clinical
setting
well that's fair enough uh is not
intended to be used to provide
liquid barrier protection what the [ __ ]
you talking about
whatever i'm just promoting his mask
it's not i guess it's not that bad
i just don't know who would want it but
some people want it so hey shout out to
your families
well i am everybody
so that was faster than i thought it
would be we got
jp coming at you uh
jp's in the news for some real really
horrific [ __ ] bro
gp's up really i mean jp
you know it's like we always say here on
the show it's the people you
most expect i ain't seen nothing
do you see the flame coming out of td
jake's butt
yo so this girl made a tick tock can i
go
uh to the restroom are you yeah you can
of course what am i what am i the
bathroom please
i always do it so bad do you have a hall
pass
it's like i need to get permission
um so this girl put out a tick tock
like a let me see the date this is from
last
yeah like a week ago saying
i'm just going to mute it because you
know it's just like a tick tuck man yeah
good
she says signed to ndaa at a famous
youtuber's house
he essayed me
uh it was just like oop and there it is
or whatever
oh man there it is she went for the
blue eyebrows that's interesting i've
never
oh there it is anyway she made a video
today
just came out like this morning super
graphic to be honest i i i can't
even show it to you guys in its entirety
can i i don't think so she's pretty
excited she's some
graphic [ __ ] yeah i mean she's not under
age
so like youtube does like when it's
underage they lose their mind
but i think the essay is also bad but
anyway her she alleges in this video
can you send me the source i don't want
to do it up re-upload
yes one second um
alleges that she went up to jake's room
and they started kissing and stuff
and then he started like trying to take
it fur take it to like third base or
fourth base or whatever
and um
she says she didn't want to and then he
said to her well then what's the point
okay fine she's like okay and that like
that makes him a douche or whatever
that's fine
but she said what happened next was that
instead of like just calling it off
um then
we were well here let me show the full
video so you guys if you guys want to
watch the full video
her channel is um
just in paradise
justine just right with that just
yeah justine um it's not funny what she
says happened
she's super i mean really graphic in her
description usually people are
which is which i think is brave and good
usually people are more vague i think
probably just because it's
embarrassing so what she says happened
after she said no
was that he grabbed so she was still
laying on the bed
he took out his his uh uh
uh what do we call it uh glitzy
this is gonna sound funny because i'm
using euphemisms but it's not
he took out his glizzy wow
man don't call it that's so much worse
it's private
why would you play that sound by zach
just my [ __ ] brain wait this is
serious
hold on let's reset
[Laughter]
[Music]
what is wrong with you
don't play any [ __ ] more vin diesel
sound bites was i'm done
i'm done
anyway what ha what happened was um
according to hers he took out his glitzy
can make you laugh every time we all
know what you're talking about just what
and then then what happened so he took
it out and she
said that he like effed her face
and like finished in her mouth real fast
and then just bailed
i was like whoa yeah i mean her
description of it is really graphic
apparently they were like talking and
flirting and then
when it came to hook up or they went
upstairs they went upstairs and they
were
kissing and stuff and she's like i don't
want to go
all the way yet and then so
yeah and they said well
nothing's gonna happen what's the point
like what oh here i'll describe
up to the moment of the really crap not
all the time but
normally everybody respects me when i
don't want to do sexual things so
she has like uh receipts and stuff like
she was definitely there at the party
you know what i mean not
to do anything else like that's normal
that's what you do
so anyway we were on his bed kissing for
a bit
and then every time he would like try to
put my it's probably too graphic
i mean i've watched the video it is very
uh graphic and
very disturbing also she describes his
behavior and he sounds so weird like he
would
he kept inviting her over back to the
house and every time she would go
you would all he wouldn't talk to her
face to face and you just text her
and you would be like hey where are you
while she's in the house
and she's like i'm over here should i
come up
let's say if he was in a room and he's
like yeah come over and then she'll come
and they'll be in the same room and they
and he's not talking to her what the
[ __ ]
super weird well according to this girl
he just is like slamming
women all the time which is fine if it's
consensual but
uh what she describes was really
disturbing and just a straight up
like s a like straight up like with hard
r and
uh what was so weird is that she said
that when you walk into the house there
is like a thing
that takes your picture and makes you
sign an nda oh yeah that's
right at the entrance you know that's
the before
she was just going to hang out there not
going to record or anything
yeah so obviously ndas don't mean
anything if a crime's committed
but she wasn't sure so she thought maybe
she can't talk about what happened
that's so shady hey you got to come hey
you want to come over my house but when
you step inside i'm gonna blast
you with a photo and make you sign an
nda it's crazy
i'm glad she came forward because i
think a lot of people get get
scared by these [ __ ] ndas yeah
they're probably just printed off the
internet
um also when they so that one
night when it happened they they were
kind of kissing you know which she was
in too
fine but then when he wanted more she's
she was not down and she said no
and then he said so what's the point
then if if nothing's gonna happen
what she said she's like fine if you
he's being a jerk
yeah that's okay he's being a douche
that's fine yeah but then he went on
but then what happened was an actual
assault but so he clearly knew she was
not
interested that's the point she made
which is yeah exactly
i'm surprised how mature and calm she is
in about it because it sounds like like
man
i was yeah i mean
dude those guys do not come from good
stock like
that like father like son i mean the
paul family is just
i don't these people are just not good
people
i mean
also what's with youtubers i mean what
the [ __ ] this this is like
in the span of uh a month or two
a month serious
essay allegations i guess it's just it's
been happening
it's just a way of coming out it's just
the youth yeah
right yeah you too that's
that's pretty good i mean
people just don't think so they just
think that's really clever thank you
thank you dan
it's like you too yeah
and i think it does take like the more
people that come
out more other victims realize that
hey hey it's not okay and that
they can also say what happened and you
know i have a feeling there's gonna be a
lot more girls coming out against jake
paul if you just
cause she said in her video she's like i
doubt he even remembers me
because he was up there with a new girl
every day you know
the fact that there's so many people and
that's his attitude i have a feeling
this isn't going to be
wait jake what is this baby oh this is
just
um weird oh
okay it's just too graphic it's just
jake being creepy and grabbing girls
unwantedly and stuff um
that india at the entrance is so bizarre
to me that's like the snapchat
invite of physical reality and it's like
um she's clearly really young
and at that age that seems very scary
like oh i signed something maybe i'm not
allowed yeah and they take their your
picture
like okay yeah we'll remember you
i may not remember you it's all
intimidation
yeah like from the moment you arrive
yeah so i think
there's probably gonna be more and i
think that
jake may end up being a uh
i don't know man i'm just not surprised
i mean we've been having warning signs
about jake i i'll be honest i don't i've
never got
the sa vibe from logan although he did
[ __ ]
jake's girlfriend and made a video about
it and it wasn't a joke
well it's not like we hang out with him
so i don't know anything
but this family is so disturbing
they had their dad you know making out
with young girls at jake's
mansion and parked in a [ __ ] bus
in the front sex tapes of gp coming at
you being
leaked i mean the whole allegedly
i like i think it was him remember him
all sweating
hey hackers oh man you guys are real
good
you guys remember
this is just bowling for adults remember
he was like i want to hire you
yeah you wanted to pay them off not to
release the video of him
or just get their info and have somebody
show up
uh bad news man these are not men of
good
moral fabric and uh well this is
actually really this is
again i just i don't know what to do
with all this because
like this is him literally and i'm
laughing because it's so ridiculous
you have uh and you have an assault
happening in dave's vlog
david's vlogs okay then you have james
charles
soliciting for minors but now you have
a influencer straight up assaulting
somebody
jake paul um
um it's just it's a lot to take in i
don't know i mean
too much money and power to a bunch of
kids with no oversight you know what the
[ __ ] is this
oh archaeology oh there's a new vid yeah
deaf noodles here give me that whatever
face blanks what do i care about that
idiot
anyway alyssa violet says the jake paul
abused her when they were together i
don't know
i believe it so here so here we go again
basically with these jake paul
accusations this is one
but i can't i definitely recommend
watching her video
um it's pretty intense
we'll see how the story develops though
i mean it just broke this morning so i
don't really have much to say about it
i'm sure there'll be more as the story
develops
but it doesn't surprise me at all i mean
you know
he is a [ __ ] it's jake paul
i mean he got kicked out of the city of
los angeles
you ever heard of that before
no wait well i'm kidding the mayor made
a statement about him though where the
mirror
right when he was like burning [ __ ] and
stuff yeah that was uh
that was right prior to him coming on
our uh show
yeah got a quite a track record of
former guests that have been cancelled
off the internet at this point i gotta
say hi lee that's true
i like to look at that wall and just see
like how many of them are in jail
let's see let's let's see crystalia
uh shane shane for sure
now jake jake
we'll see we'll see he's looking
this is a really bad i mean can you let
him box if he's pro
if this is like a proven thing because
his whole thing is like this big boxing
match that he's working up towards now
based off the history based off the
history of um
prominent boxers and allegations against
them i
don't think that this yeah it's gonna
stop it like that we're like that's good
this was actually a requirement to get
uh
yeah that'll sell more tickets
right where can people find her video
her channel is called um
i'll put a link in the description you
guys can find it but her channel
is called
somebody god
you just had it pulled up in the dark
right
you guys posted about uh a re-upload
oh doc as well my computer's frozen
oh just in paradise justine paradise
on youtube right
so um that's it
i mean you want to talk about bad baby
thing either that's your kind of
you're the bad baby stan yeah you're the
you're the bad you are the bad baby
um i don't know if you want to
it's another like bad vibes situation
well doctor phil's a douche i've always
hated dr phil
you're telling me like he brings on
little kids
dr phil has always been the biggest
douche on tv
like okay so i'll give you the
the brief on you want me to pull up the
video or you want to give a brief
um yeah pull up her video but
basically so when she went on his show
she was like 13 or 14 and
he um so i guess
like as a solution he he tells the
parents to send
someone like her to this like camp it's
like some boot camp
yeah in the middle of nowhere and
basically she's saying it was so
traumatizing
and she's she's pissed at him because
why is he sending kids there
it's he and he's acting like he's in no
affiliation with them she was 13 when
she was when she was sent there
so she was 13 they came and just picked
her up
one night at night without no one told
her anything really they actually do
that no
warning you know anything and they
pretty much kidnapped her
and she didn't know where she was going
how what nothing
her parent her her mom signed her up for
she basically felt like she was
kidnapped oh she didn't even know her
mom had consented they just come and
pick her up
the mom didn't say anything to her oh
that is
that's awesome so [ __ ] up i think
that's part is that they come again in
the middle of the night you don't know
so and when she got there it was like
she's saying it's very abusive
they wouldn't let her sleep for like
three days every time she would start
falling asleep
that's literally what they do in like
pow torture camps it's torture
um no no proper food no they don't have
a phone or anything why don't they just
lobotomize it it's in the middle of
nowhere too so like
you're a kid you have no one to go to if
something is wrong
like you can't go anywhere you have no
one to connect with anyone
um and she said the staff is all in on
with each other so like if you have a
complaint
it's it's like you got no one to talk to
because they're all gonna protect each
other the staff
that makes sense um and she said
it got it like it's so bad that like
okay she felt like tortured and all that
but besides that there was
one girl that is suing that place
over sexual assault she's saying she was
awarded
yeah essayed and that when she came to
like
complain about it to one of the staff
they didn't listen or didn't do anything
about it
so when she saw that lawsuit bad baby
she decided to speak up about it too
and she said one other really crazy
story that happened while she was there
is that one of the kids
in their murder or m word
a staff member while she was there while
she was there
and what yes and and like they didn't
tell the kids anything about what
happened
or what's being done about it and
they're like
so you're telling like she's saying so
you're telling me that one of the kids
here is basically like
m word and we're just like
okay i don't know um so
it sounds like a really bad place really
bad
and and and like dr phil's show they
they promote that place they send kids
there yeah they even listed on their
website
as like a solution for kids you know it
reminds me of that judge who was being
paid
to send he was getting kicked back to
send kids to juvenile
for like [ __ ] um they have some
affiliation with them she also said that
the the mom signed like a consent form
that
that place can provide information to
the dr phil show
or something like that oh bro so yeah
because they film it and [ __ ]
they're definitely like you know
benefiting from it
yeah do you really care about her you're
just trying to watch her get tortured
um s-i-m-p is there any part of this you
want to watch because it's
so yeah that's the thing i don't know
which part i it's
basically everything that i've just
described anyways
it has 16 million or six million views
so
maybe it'll actually make an impact i
hope so that it sounds really wrong and
like
it's actually a kid that does need help
and
what you're doing is the complete
opposite right
and she felt like no one was really
helping her and she didn't have anyone
to talk to
she tried to send letters to her mom and
it's like she knows that the staff was
reading them and like she doesn't even
know
i don't know her mom was not responding
i guess i don't know what exactly
happened
but she was like i'll do anything just
get me out of here
she's like a refugee it's like a it's
like a pow camp
yeah back in the day that used to be
like fine i remember that was like
kind of like uh a trope of these shows
we were like we're going to send these
trouble
kids to boot camp and scare them
straight so you seem scared straight
where they send kids into prison and
they'll get like uh
tortured by inmates you remember that
[ __ ] scared straight
i don't know if i've seen that i've been
recently watching that
it's crazy man this [ __ ] is so twisted i
i think they thought that was helpful in
some way but real
the truth is it's all about just
entertainment content for them
i mean it doesn't take a rocket science
to know that this is not
how to treat a child just to send them
in the middle of nowhere and like
where people are being like killed and
assaulted yeah like i mean
so this is the first video where she is
basically breaking the silence and
talking about her experience there and
how wrong it is
and she's calling dr phil out and asking
him to
apologize um of course he did not
and then i guess on a news appearance he
was asked about it
that's her second video she reacts to it
i can pull that up
a day later they have us all uh every
kid that's at turn around there was
awesomeness
like listening to it was incident i know
some of y'all was this place and
that place was controversial jimmy was
like i said like he
must have known too the show must have
known those things were in the news
because i think any place that was
actually concerned about rehabilitating
children in any meaningful way
would say no we're not going to send you
clips of her for your [ __ ] show
right right because there's definitely
some i mean
yeah yeah
i wonder how many kids he sent there i
mean this should be investigated this
seems like a serious guy i've always got
the
worst vibes from dr phil's chip monk ass
looking face like he's the epic meme guy
though oh
oh smith yeah exactly i've got the worst
one because he sits there
all holier than that tries to judge
everyone
sit there like dude you're just
is he even a [ __ ] doctor by the way
like does he actually have a doctor
as a doctor i'm not
i mean if he's supporting a place like
that then he's not educated about
therapy like if you're trying to help a
kid that's not the way to help
it's not necessarily that he's not
educated or that he's not a real doctor
but he's
he doesn't have he's a piece of [ __ ] he
doesn't have any scruples exactly yeah
he's just a [ __ ] he's willing to do
whatever for
entertainment is he a doctor that's what
i want to know i mean i'm looking up
right now i'm almost certain he is
okay well uh yeah he has a phd degree in
clinical psychology
phd and being a [ __ ] [ __ ] from
clinical psychology
okay and torturing youth one of the
other staff members that was there at
the time alicia who was the
daughter of the nurse alicia
she was also injured
and two years later she died and she was
also left disabled after being attacked
by clay
so the mother of um getting like like
so that's the in that same case
that same incident when one person
passed
yeah um she's saying another staff
member got injured so bad
oh my god yeah from that saying
she was married to the brother of the
president of the program
which i also believe is a conflict of
interest i don't know why they would do
that
so it was really sad let's watch it
anyway yeah let's watch dr phil's
response it's interesting because she's
gone on to become so
famous that she's capable of actually
speaking out in a meeting
yeah which is pretty great people saying
he hasn't renewed his uh
license in decades i mean he has a
doctorate he
he's a doctor but yeah if he's not a
current doctor but he's not a practicing
psychologist that's the distinction
man that guy took a oath does he know
he's a phd he didn't take oath
he's not a medical doctor yeah i never
quack i shall harm
i shall i shall harm all children i
shall do harm i shall entertain
people at the expense of children ugly
you are disgusting i'm going to kill you
that's just what phd talks like that
that's not appropriate by any means
anyway i think you did a good job
summarizing that one so let's go to
i would say if anyone is interested in
the story
just go and watch her video because it
is really interesting story
um here is dr phil
who's basically not avoided all uh
avoided acknowledging how long until it
comes out that he's got some financial
interest in this range by the way
well it means i mean he obviously he
does anyways if they have some
partnership where they're sending him
footage yes i i don't know that because
like the show makes a lot of money
the cash generated from this ranch is
probably nothing but
what what's the most valuable is that
they're willing to send them footage of
a so-called rehabilitation
right yeah and you know and i'll tell
you what
the more uh extreme the footage the more
entertaining it is for the show
and i bet oh yeah you know there's
another point that she makes because um
she's saying like you've profited off of
that one clip of me that became such a
meme
yeah you've profited so much money like
it could be hundreds of millions
because any she says just on
their channels like on youtube it has
hundreds of millions of viewers yeah and
anywhere he goes any appearance that's
what people ask him about
like he's on the joe rogan talking about
it he's everywhere talking about this
yeah yeah
and it's it's i mean just right there
he has a vested interest and he has a
you know financial interest
in those kids and oh yeah and the reason
i said it is because
she said when she goes out on stage
they're on the show they tell her like
you know be
right be extreme it makes a better show
well these talk show producers are known
to be the worst people in the world
so i have no i i i can totally imagine
being possible
that the producers are constantly
talking to these people at the ranch
about like we need this type of footage
make it more extreme we need to get her
more suffering go more erratic or more
crazy i'm saying even on the doctor phil
the initial they encourage her to act
crazy yeah
for sure i would love to know the the i
think if there's an investigation
between their relationship and this
ranch there's gonna be some
i don't know that it's it may even be dr
phil paying the
i mean he is paying the rent there's
some people in the chat saying that he
founded the ranch
i i'm trying to look i haven't been able
to verify that i don't know if that's
true i think he they paid the ranch
for torturing these kids and getting
them good footage
that's the relationship that i'm for
seeing
dr phil you are a weird one or he's like
what is it doctor phil you are a grinch
i don't know i'll ask you about torture
we're not
involved should i walk yeah go back a
little yeah go back i want to hear what
he said
you want me to watch the whole thing
she's got money now she got like
disclaimers and [ __ ] like what's up dr
phil
you ain't the only one with money now
[ __ ] i'm team bad baby
yeah even with the h's in there bad baby
we love that yo can i give actually get
shout out to this girl who she went on
dr phil
and was such a character she made a
whole [ __ ] career
rap career personality but and she's
like
just turned 18. yeah she is a bad baby
yeah shout out to his family like i mean
dude she kind of [ __ ] is a hustler
it's really messed up that she goes on
this show gives him like
the greatest content he ever got and
then she gets
thrown into this camp and has no one to
talk to
she has no help like it makes our life
worse it really it should it's not a
it's a content ranch
it's not a rehabilitation and by the way
why is it called a ranch i find that
disturbing what do they
because it is a ranch it's like in utah
or something like in the middle of
nowhere
literally it isn't right yeah it's the
content ranch
send them off to the content ranch yeah
oh since i made my breaking code silence
video
i have gotten hundreds and thousands of
emails and
dms and all type of stuff with multiple
kids wanting to
give me their stories it just shows me
what is that like
like you know i'm not the only one that
went through these kind of things it
feels good to
be able to relate i just want is that
like they think their hair
yeah it's like those baby hairs oh she's
just vibing with it or usually girls put
it back
yeah because i never i've never seen a
hairstyle like this
no it's a thing
i didn't know about the baby hairs i
think it's a thing in
certain cultures where they do it like
that but do you have those baby hairs
i definitely do but i don't know i don't
it's just not a thing where i grow up
but it's a thing in some places
okay vibe check yeah passes the vibe
have your kid watch somebody get
murdered have them get
yeah should i watch the rest of it no
that's pretty much it
good for her i don't like him
you know it's crazy when you look back
at like uh
i've told this story before but these
kind of talk shows are the most
immoral i'm not way off camera the most
immoral these producers will do anything
and cook up any situation
to make it more interesting there was a
netflix documentary
about that was sally jesse raphael i
think
and it was like at the peak of these
really sensational talk shows
and so they had a prompt they said write
in
can you guys look up the facts of this
story it was a netflix documentary about
it where
someone he called in his friend they
said if you have a secret lover
oh yeah you kind of talked about it
recently on the plug
and so he called in his secret lover and
it turns out it was
his friend a guy and um
apparently he was um
not he was straight but also his family
was like super
hardcore christian and homophobic and
stuff and
it turned into this whole crazy thing
where um
his friend the guy who he called in and
humiliated on tv
ended up murdering him so
there was just there's a lot of shenani
i mean shenanigans put it lightly yet
these shows are horrible well
yep what is this one
what we guessed my brand told producers
that she wanted to give her 13 year old
danielle it's from 2000 to turn things
around
we together talked about it we refer
it's in that room now this is like a
follow-up
[Music]
you know this there's no showing okay
whatever
yeah they made a whole dude they they
milked the [ __ ] out of her
story arc
can you guys find details about that
story i was talking about
jenny jones jenny jones it was on jenny
jones
anyway what else we got we got farts
we got oh i got another one ela this
one's good for you
longest fingernails on a woman ever gets
clipped after 29 years
man i can't believe you can the body
even enables this kind of growth but
look at this
oh you got it you found it so before we
move on to that
well where where is it he's sent
oh yeah that's him i recognize him
the gay crush murder
yeah that [ __ ] was crazy um
basically uh the
here the guy he murdered a gay admirer
three days after the victim revealed his
same-sex crush
on the guy on the jenny jones talk i
wish i could find that clip because
it's really interesting because he just
seems like embarrassed and is it going
along with it
but he was just so upset about being
humiliated on tv like that
um
yeah can you guys find the clip of it
happening because i found it really
interesting
because it really i thought it was
really insightful to how
the victim mentality because it looks
like he's totally fine
he's obviously uncomfortable and he's
trying to go along with it but like
he was so deeply affected by that
because oftentimes from victims you'll
be like oh well you went along with the
if you didn't why didn't you stop but
then that kind of thing you know
um what was the show it was
jesse yeah jesse jones i said that so
i'll you guys can't find the club
i'm looking for it now i think i found
it
you you
there we go what is this
yeah this is now to meet donna and scott
now donna has been helping scott
pursue his secret crush on john jenny
jones was one of many
daytime talk show hosts in the 90s that
had viewers tuning in
no no no can you cut off guard
seem to find humor in the moment did you
have any idea that he'd like you this
much
um no no no i did not can you tell us
what your status is are
you involved with anybody or um no okay
why did you do that
but one of those revelations would turn
deadly
okay calm down okay
[Music]
okay why did you do that
in 1995 the jenny jones show taped an
episode on secret admirers
32 year old scott amador revealed he had
a crush on an acquaintance
24 year old jonathan schmidt 24 why are
they even doing this
he was 32 they brought in a 24 year old
what the [ __ ] they're not even like
close in age that's just creepy
brought the two together to see if there
was a love connection
well guess what it's scott that has the
crush on you you lied to me
you said you lied to me it's erupted in
excitement
and a surprise schmitz while caught off
guard
seemed to find humor in the moment did
you have any idea that he'd like you
this much
um no no no i did not can you tell us
what your status is are you involved
with anybody or
um no but i am uh definitely a
heterosexual i guess you could say
[Applause]
so i think the production team lied to
him about the whole context and they
brought him out and humiliated him
and they were like they were like so the
girl that's sitting there
it's like one of them has a crush on him
or what's the
i think he just came under the premise
that so you have a secret admirer
okay and his friend probably it was an
elaborate
date you know what i mean later i am not
gay 32 years old but he immediately
turned to him and said uh
you lied to me mm-hmm anyway these shows
don't give a [ __ ]
about anything why would you bring a 24
year old to me a 32 year old anyone
watch some
lady with big ass nails oh god
is that amazing that your body's nails
just like will just not stop growing
here we go it's time to get them
all right i'm out
we got the fingernails i have a few
funny videos [ __ ] it let's watch it all
we're in deep now
we got will i am we got uh new videos to
end
yeah let's end on a high note these are
really good notes um
okay so okay okay
okay i think i've watched this before
yeah
but i don't know if i don't remember and
it's so
good oh i i actually think that we
watched on the podcast but like
almost four years ago now okay like wow
so this guy gets so drunk at a party
i thought this is only something that
happened in slapstick full screen
doesn't help much the guy
literally thinks himself blocking
himself in the mirror
okay is this just alcohol or is there
something else
you ever oh my god
this is the greatest thing ever i don't
remember this video
you don't okay because i don't remember
if we did watch it but
dude
[Music]
i mean this is like a charlie chaplin
yeah
after you now after you
can't believe what he's seeing
this is something yeah
there he found the bathroom wow
wait is this me right now oh you already
made a thumbnail that's a good ass
thumbnail
ian looks like he went to pee
nice good job dude
oh he's nice yeah donald trump
please stand up yeah can you please when
he gets back we'll have to compliment
him
all right the next two
i'm sorry but there's really only one
way to categorize it is that it's just
[Music]
i don't want to say it all right
i don't know what you're thinking about
i think
well whenever it is no saying
are you sure ian's back
ian great job on the thumbnail i just
saw it on the on the explorer
good work on that god bless
it's just like well the commonality
between these two is just like
they're just they're big people and
probably too big for the ride they're
too big for the ride
and tragedy strikes i mean that's the
truth
like there's like some people are too
short for rides and
others are too heavy for them all right
let's watch it well you want to battle
you watch this and you tell me
you tell me they could hear this guy
right here he can't hold on
i mean i feel like that's the problem
with the ride
no looking
[Applause]
holding on to like 100
that's gotta be terrifying poor guys
[Applause]
the next one's actually even funnier if
you can believe that
the next one i was actually crying when
i saw this next one
um oh my god we got to mute this one but
bro i could not stop
laughing when i saw this
i don't know
[Laughter]
that's my nightmare
actually i don't think that one has to
do with their weight no it's not
yeah it's just a defective function also
she's not even that
like heavy oh i take it back
[Laughter]
oh
come here oh my god dude
[Laughter]
dude
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
oh my god
super fast
spinning so fast
don't ever ride this [ __ ] no carnival
right bro i swear to god
i swear don't ever go you [ __ ]
it looks like a ninja turtle thing like
the back looks good
turtle shell look everyone's just having
a good time
oh yeah it is like a ninja turtle
[Laughter]
and this guy's just filming laughing his
ass off
oh somebody just somebody in the chat
just remind me they said that this is
like the helicopter video
which is probably the other time i've
seen you laugh i'm sorry
and she's below and it starts spinning
like super late
i don't remember you don't remember that
okay hold on
let me find it this is the funniest
[ __ ] they're saying they think it's
in the mall of america
i was thinking it looked like a mall
the riders the riders have a certain
amount of control once the ride starts
oh really just keep it straight or start
to tilt it
thought is when she turned her arms
locked or something
down when it stops that shouldn't happen
it looks like she's literally falling
out
[Applause]
everyone else is just so straight and
her ass is spilling out
she's gonna fall out i mean that's not
right
look at her she's like
she's holding up with their feet
[Laughter]
i can't do it
as soon as you see the thumbnail for
this
[Applause]
oh sorry to her shout out to her family
do you remember oh yeah now i remember
bro i don't know why this one's so funny
either it's just like
i mean nobody gets hurt that's good it's
just such a [ __ ]
hilarious like they're trying to rescue
it's so [ __ ] up
they're trying to rescue this person
who's like obviously
like seriously severely injured and they
get
they get them rotating so [ __ ] fast
look definitely it's going
that's
spinning
like i've never seen anything even spin
that fast there's a bot
there's someone injured in there it's
this part here look at that
look at that speed
that's not good that's not good
look at that
god is something so funny about like the
rescuer just making it work
especially when they don't get
and hurt i love they just take off with
their ass to dangling behind them
like what kind of rescue is this i think
they needed to get away from the uh
but it was the area that was causing the
uh the wind from the turbine to
spin her so what is going on in
that person's her mind she's in this
thing
i think she's probably passed out yeah i
think so that's what it
they say i think i mean the amount of
yeah the g-force of spinning that fast
lord help me and i guess that's what i
find so funny about the other
firefighter who lights everyone on fire
it's just something so funny about being
there to help
and making everything so much worse oh
yeah
we have a button for that yeah it i had
to take away your button because you
switched to mac
doesn't work on mac but i still have it
in this system
should i open that i mean we've watched
that one so many times yeah
that is literally everything
we actually we actually got to the
bottom of the dock yeah it never
happened
i'm looking over it wow
i probably have some diarrhea with
mushrooms in it for
oh we have more details about the rescue
when you're after oh there's like
oh she's doing oh oh
oh well i mean they didn't do anything
wrong necessarily did they
woman is suing i mean hey they say they
were trying right
let's see i mean spitting from a
helicopter this is kind of a freak thing
wasn't it
yeah um the woman
has been identified she tripped
somewhere on a trail
oh yeah she was totally fine she just
tripped
and then she needed help getting down
and then these guys came and picked her
up and gave her the spin of a lifetime
that's the best
they call it they wrapped her up in
what's called a strokes
basket which is funny because i that she
was definitely having a stroke in there
i vaguely remember when this happened
hearing that this is sort of
not like super common thing but it's
like it's a thing that happens with
these rescue helicopters occasionally
sure so that makes sense i mean you know
[ __ ] happens i mean maybe there's some
other yeah maybe there's some other
details how about don't go [ __ ]
hiking and
for like i don't want a [ __ ] trip
yeah come on idiot
you took a little bit of a tumble but i
mean before we make idiots
out of ourselves maybe there maybe there
is some other circumstance to this that
we're not aware of that
yeah yeah some people pay for a spin
like that
all right that's that
see i'm reading she expressed to the
first responders she did not want to be
taken off the trail by the helicopter
despite the plaintiff's wishes what are
they going to do leave her there today
the decision to transport off the trail
by helicopter air rescue
i mean if she really was like no don't
put me on a helicopter and they're like
no we're going to do it and then do that
dan i know what if she wants to i don't
know
can't you can't do that they can't they
can't just she's like no don't take my
help all right well bye ma'am and then
she like
comes like the next day and she's
they're all [ __ ] like help
i'll take the helicopter now
they can't get out over there i don't
know good point i mean
it's funny though it's extra funny
knowing that she had this phobia of
being picked up
there she was like please don't put me
on like 100 rpm like
i swear it'll be fine just get on the
head it's fine we do this every day
five minutes later look just face your
fears
it's like the ranch
man that shit's crazy
[Music]
oh she got injured abe said oh no yeah
her physical examination knows she had
uh what the hell is that
she had pat bleeding shoulders and feet
swelling
and sounds like a bunch of lawyer talk
to me
like she had patches of bleeding
under her skin that's called a bruise
yeah exactly on both shoulders and feet
as well
i'm sure it did but no i know but that's
like when lawyers are trying to like
drum up like all this crazy damage
sorry i'm just killing the buzz you know
what happened is this is when super
viral
and
let's see on the shoulders and feet as
well as swelling and bruising on both
eyes it's like
yeah um also apparently she lost
a feeling in her left apparently her
left
leg went uh paralyzed
i'm not a cat i made that up she
actually died
blood in her right membrane and both
it's a bunch of [ __ ] oh it's ct scan
found
she had among other things soft tissue
swelling
over part of her skull i found no yeah
it sounds like
it sounds like something
yeah next time you get a bruise describe
it if you would as a
patch of bleeding under the skin
with slight swelling
maybe she maybe should hey hey none of
my business
right forget about it right
i wonder what i'm gonna eat tonight
today
so now i've picked up this [ __ ] fried
chicken
so now like not only can i
not order mexican food
i don't see why you you really to
stick to like only eating what they
provide you that's the idea
okay chicken wednesday you know it's
just so extreme i mean
shouldn't you be able to maybe once a
week
it's easy that's the idea i mean that's
the idea
i mean they give you the food you eat
the food if i if you give me sunday i'm
gonna [ __ ] sunday in the ass
yeah fried chicken wednesday baby you
give me wednesday i'm gonna [ __ ] that
fried chicken you know what i mean like
don't let me slip up
okay [ __ ] wednesday night baby
[ __ ] fried chicken
i i need to just see some results that's
it and you know and then i can loosen up
i'm just
everything i try it's like nothing ever
changes and i'm sick of even talking
about it
because everyone gets invested and then
nothing happens and i just feel like
pathetic
thank you zach it's just everyone gets
so invested and everybody's rooting for
me but then i just keep trying [ __ ] and
nothing happens i'm a [ __ ] failure
and nothing happens and i'm just sick of
talking about it you guys
and then you guys get so invested i just
i just need to shut up about it
and put up or shut up
[Music]
thank you for your sympathy
so i'm fine i'm currently trying to put
up okay
and we will shut up you guys can say
whatever you want
to turn on him
it's like woody woodpecker all right
listen listening it's been another great
one my friends yeah
another week three hours of wonders
ela has come through here we appreciate
your presence i mean we're in the
presence of greatness
ceo
[Applause]
i love fridays fried chicken
fries
hope you guys have a great safe
beautiful wonderful weekend i hope
you're all
planning to get those vaccines every
adult is eligible the middle of this
month yes
so whatever it is whatever however
healthy or whatever you are
you can get a shot in like a week did
you get your shots
and i encourage that r kelly why are you
promoting fascism right now
oh you guys i don't know if you saw it
but i made some tweet about prep
passport the vaccine passports and it
was like
all over every conservative media like
literally
uh infowars oh my god there was another
big one
um info i was on info wars you guys it's
fun
okay i figured i didn't need to involve
you and all that
i'm off the rails
so i like that all right guys
all right peace and love thank you for
watching
another place out with our kids not a
fun one it's
but place out with r kelly i don't have
that one
we don't have it on standby i've got it
but what but then does his thing with
the fades
okay just play it play it out play zelda
and then make it
and then everybody shut the [ __ ] up
i got it i got it do you have your
passport
did you get your shots girl would you
like to come back with rob to
[Music]
girl would you like to come back with
rob
to america america
america
do you have your passport
[Music]
americans
you